[Música]
vuelven los diálogos presenciales entre
rusia y ucrania el presidente de turquía
recep tayib erdogán se reunirá con los
delegados de ambas partes antes de la
negociación en su país mientras que la
onu busca un cese al fuego
las fuerzas ucranianas retomando el
control de dos lugares donde
predominaban los rusos se trata de ir
fin a las afueras de kiev y de una
localidad de la región de odessa el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr es el
esquí que sí solo que todavía es pronto
para hablar de seguridad
el expresidente de honduras juan orlando
hernández será extraditado a estados
unidos por cargos de narcotráfico hoy la
corte suprema de justicia hondureña
ratificó la decisión y pronto llegará a
suelo estadounidense para enfrentar el
juicio
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y es un placer
acompañarlos las delegaciones de rusia y
ucrania se reunirán mañana en turquía
para discutir una salida negociada a la
guerra el presidente turco recep tayib
erdogán afirmó que antes de las
conversaciones se encontrara con las
partes y agregó que las llamadas con sus
homólogos vladimir putin y bolo dimes el
esquí avanzan en una dirección positiva
este será el primer encuentro presencial
que tienen los enviados ucranianos y
rusos luego de que los ministros de
relaciones exteriores se reunieran el 10
de marzo veamos más en el siguiente
reporte
los negociadores rusos llegaron a
estambul el lunes por la tarde la nueva
ronda de conversaciones con los
ucranianos se iniciará el martes pero en
punto a una cumbre entre los dos
presidentes de rusia y ucrania que
vladimir selenski reclama moscú sin dar
una negativa definitiva pospone el plazo
sérguei lávrov dice que esa reunión es
prematura
vladimir putin dijo que nunca rechazaría
una reunión con el presidente es el skin
el conflicto entre ucrania lleva mucho
tiempo latente durante años se han
acumulado muchos problemas así que
reunirse para decirse que te parece yo
creo que sería contraproducente el jefe
de la diplomacia rusa también condiciona
la reunión al cumplimiento de las
demandas de moscú en las negociaciones
en particular rusia pide la
desmilitarización y neutralidad de
ucrania lo que llama desnazificación del
país así como el reconocimiento por kiev
de la anexión de crimea por parte de
rusia en 2014 o la independencia de las
llamadas repúblicas pro rusas del tumbas
unas horas antes en el lado ucraniano
volodymyr selenski había dicho que
estaba dispuesto a compromisos que no
son menos importantes y apoyo a esto
entiendo que es imposible hacer que
rusia abandone el territorio por
completo que conducirá a la tercera
guerra mundial entiendo completamente
soy consciente es por eso que estoy
diciendo si esto es un compromiso de
hecho volver a donde todo comenzó y
vamos a tratar de resolver la cuestión
del donbass y la compleja cuestión del
donbass sus libros donde ucrania dice
que tomen está dispuesta a comprometerse
en la cuestión de la no adhesión a la
otan pero exige un alto el fuego
inmediato y la retirada de las tropas
rusas y ya se había celebrado una sesión
de negociación para ella el 10 de marzo
en turquía en antalya a nivel de
ministros de asuntos exteriores pero no
llegó a ningún progreso concreto y
paralelamente hay otra negociación que
está en curso el multimillonario ruso
roman abramovich dueño del club de
fútbol inglés el chelsea también intenta
mediar entre los mandatarios de rusia y
ucrania sin embargo luego de las
conversaciones de paz abramovich habría
tenido síntomas de un presunto
envenenamiento según la web de
investigación
behling cat y según el portal
periodístico wall street journal veamos
más en el informe
el propietario del club de fútbol
chelsea fue envenenado a principios de
este mes eso es lo que informan el wall
street journal y el sitio de
investigación de link art
roman abramovich participaba en
conversaciones de paz con negociadores
ucranianos en quien tanto él como sus
homólogos ucranianos sufrieron síntomas
como dolor de ojos y descamación de la
piel tras la reunión sin embargo el
ministro de asuntos exteriores de
ucrania no se mostró convencido de la
veracidad del informe y aconsejó a quien
vaya a negociar con la federación rusa
que no coman y beban y preferiblemente
que evite tocar cualquier superficie eso
es de primera mano
en segundo lugar todas las historias
alguien oyó algo en alguna parte ahora
hay muchas de ese tipo porque todo el
mundo está sediento de noticias de
sensaciones poco después de que salieran
a la luz las acusaciones un funcionario
estadounidense no identificado citado
por reuters
sugirió que la enfermedad podría deberse
a factores ambientales se pidió al
multimillonario ruso que ayudara a
negociar el fin de la guerra con los
funcionarios ucranianos occidente había
impuesto duras sanciones contra la
oligarquía cercano a vladimir putin que
puso a la venta el chelsea y
posteriormente el gobierno británico
congeló sus activos en el país y
mientras los diálogos multilaterales
avanzan la onu intentará un posible alto
al fuego en ucrania el secretario
general del organismo antonio guterres
precisó que la intención de explorar un
cese de hostilidades es poder negociar
un eventual acuerdo de paz el encargado
de la onu para realizar las gestiones es
martín griffiths el secretario general
adjunto para asuntos humanitarios
que pronto él pueda ir a ucrania y a
rusia
y ha pasado más de un mes desde que
rusia invadió a ucrania y hasta podría
estar recuperando terreno el ejército
ucraniano ha retomado bastante en la
región de o deza el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski ratificó que sus
fuerzas ya retomaron el control de la
ciudad de irving cerca de kiev les
explicamos los detalles en el siguiente
reporte
alivio para los angustiados residentes
de ir pin el ejército de vladimir putin
ha estado accediendo la estratégica
ciudad en la ruta noroeste hacia kiev
pero ahora el alcalde de la ciudad ha
anunciado que las fuerzas ucranianas han
retomado el control
tenemos buenas noticias
irving ha sido liberada
los mismos
entendemos que habrá más ataques contra
nuestra ciudad y la defenderemos con
valentía el ping es ucrania gloria a
ucrania gloria a los héroes fuego y
hierro en flow
una afirmación que aún no ha sido
verificada de forma independiente sin
embargo tras semanas de combates los
residentes que huyeron hablaron de los
horrores que presenciaron decimos los
autos que intentaron salir por su cuenta
fueron aplastados por los tanques autos
con gente adentro
más al sur va están acá es una ciudad en
ruinas donde la vida se ha detenido es
como una ciudad fantasma pero entre los
escombros quedan algunos fragmentos de
vida las fuerzas ucranianas también
lograron retomar esta ciudad que estaba
en manos del ejército ruso gran parte de
ésta ha sido reducida a escombros
disparaban contra nuestras casas nos
atormentaban mucho sean de peluche es
inhumano esta gente que dicen ser
nuestros hermanos están mintiendo al
mundo entero están mintiendo a su propia
gente no habrá perdón que dios se apiade
de ellos y quebrar yo soy un árbol de
queda por ver qué impacto tendrán estos
avances ucranianos para rusia y para la
guerra el presidente de estadounidense
joe biden defendió las palabras que
pronunció desde polonia contra el
mandatario ruso vladimir putin al final
de su discurso el sábado va a ir él dijo
que putin no podía permanecer en el
poder los críticos lo señalaron de
querer un cambio de régimen en moscú hoy
el presidente sostuvo que nadie estaba
hablando de derrocar a putin sino que él
expresó lo que llamó indignación moral
por lo que sentía hacia el líder ruso
esto fue lo que dijo el líder de la casa
blanca número uno no estoy retrocediendo
en nada el hecho de que estaba
expresando más indignación
así que quiero dejar claro que no estaba
entonces ni estoy ahora articulando un
cambio de política estaba expresando la
indignación moral que siento no pido
disculpas
cambiamos de tema y vamos a francia en
la recta final de las elecciones
presidenciales de este 10 de abril a
partir de hoy los medios de comunicación
deben dar cobertura equitativa a todos
los 12 candidatos también se podrá
publicar vídeos folletos y carteles les
contamos la historia
después de meses de luchar por
posicionarse de buscar el apoyo de
funcionarios locales y de hacer
apariciones en los medios de
comunicación los 12 candidatos franceses
a las elecciones presidenciales de 2022
entraron en la recta final
este lunes comienza oficialmente la
campaña a menos de dos semanas de la
primera vuelta los carteles electorales
aparecen por primera vez en todo el país
ahora los residentes pueden venir a
echar un vistazo a su candidato y elegir
uno con sabiduría debería decir a partir
de ahora los medios de comunicación
franceses están obligados a dar a cada
candidato el mismo tiempo de cobertura
independientemente de sus posibilidades
de éxito los vídeos de campaña también
aparecen por primera vez en la
televisión pública de acuerdo con las
estrictas leyes electorales del país
antes de esta apertura varios candidatos
celebraron actos de campaña para
intentar animar a sus seguidores de cara
a la recta final la eterna candidata de
extrema derecha marine lepén estuvo en
guadalupe donde fue recibida con
protestas y abucheos por parte de
manifestantes anti racistas
y su rival el ix m celebró un gran mitin
en parís el candidato de la izquierda
jean luc mélenchon estuvo en marsella
donde dijo que votar por él sería la
mejor manera de alejar la extrema
derecha los votantes franceses acudirán
a las urnas el domingo 10 de abril sin
ningún candidato tiene una mayoría
absoluta los dos más votados pasarán a
una segunda vuelta dos semanas después
el 24 de abril y ahora hablemos de kobe
19 porque en china aplicará en el
aislamiento más estricto que ha habido
desde el que se implementó en usan
cuando apareció el virus y es que dos
zonas de shanghai la ciudad más grande
del país entrarán en cuarentena durante
cinco días para tomar pruebas masivas en
beijing nuestro corresponsal
adrián foncillas nos explicaba la
información previamente
si no ha confinado shanghai su capital
financiera de 26 millones de habitantes
nunca antes había cerrado una ciudad tan
poblada lo que ha aconsejado una inédita
fórmula por fases desde hoy hasta el
viernes estarán encerrados los que viven
al este del río huangpu y entonces les
relevarán los que viven en el oeste la
decisión se ha tomado después de que
aquellos confinamientos quirúrgicos
durante semanas en algunos barrios y
complejos inmobiliarios se hayan
rebelado incapaces de atajar la pandemia
las autoridades habían desmentido los
rumores que apuntaban a un confinamiento
inminente y el sábado aún lo rechazaban
alegando la gran relevancia que tiene
shanghai para la economía no sólo
nacional sino también internacional pero
los datos del domingo que arrojaban casi
3.500 nuevos casos es decir el 70 por
ciento de los totales del país les
hicieron cambiar de opinión china sufre
desde marzo el peor rebrote desde los
días de wuhan primero fue la provincia
de jilín después fue extensión y ahora
le ha tocado a shanghai que dos años y
medio después
padeciendo el primer confinamiento
masivo en noticias latinoamericanas la
corte suprema de justicia de honduras
ratificó la extradición del ex
presidente juan orlando hernández a eeuu
este país lo solicita por tráfico de
drogas y conspiración por porte de armas
de fuego y dispositivos destructivos la
familia del exmandatario respondió que
era un golpe duro para ellos se espera
que los próximos días fernández sea
entregado a las autoridades
estadounidenses donde enfrentará a su
juicio
juan orlando hernández será extraditado
a eeuu así lo ratificó la corte suprema
de justicia de honduras que rechazó su
apelación luego de analizar todos los
agravios y los elementos que fueron
presentados por la defensa técnica en la
apelación planteada ha resuelto no al
lugar el recurso de apelación planteado
lo cual significa que se confirma la
decisión del juez de primera instancia
de conceder la extradición del ciudadano
juan orlando hernández el ex presidente
hondureño es acusado por la justicia
estadounidense de conspiración para
fabricar distribuir y poseer una
sustancia controlada y llevarla a eeuu y
usar o portar armas de fuego o ayudar a
instigar al uso de las mismas según el
portavoz del poder judicial la decisión
contó con el voto unánime de los
magistrados en el cargo de narcotráfico
y 13 contra 2 con respecto al cargo de
uso de armas
hernández de 53 años dijo en una carta
que compartió su esposa en su cuenta de
'twitter' que es inocente todo cambió
todos los planes que tenía para mi
retiro después de tantos años de trabajo
al final concluido en la posibilidad de
que enfrentar cargos por tres cadenas
perpetuas podría llevarme a convertirme
en un muerto
esto es una venganza de los carteles es
una trama orquestada para que ningún
gobierno vuelva a hacerle frente el
exmandatario fue detenido en su
domicilio el 15 de febrero para la
petición del gobierno estadounidense y
desde entonces ha permanecido recluido
en la dirección nacional de fuerzas
especiales de la policía nacional la
detención se produjo en menos de tres
semanas después de que hernández dejara
su cargo y tras años de acusaciones de
la fiscalía estadounidense sobre
presuntos vínculos con el narcotráfico
el presidente de el salvador nadie
bukele le advirtió a los pandilleros que
paren de matar o que si no sus
compañeros que están en prisión pagarán
por ellos el mandatario señaló que ya a
los presos les restringieron algunas
medidas y es que el país entró en
régimen de decepción desde el domingo
cuando el congreso lo decretó a petición
de google este suspende algunas
garantías constitucionales
además el mandatario hizo su advertencia
a través de twitter una red social que
ha usado como herramienta política
mensaje a las pandillas tenemos 16 mil
home voice en nuestro poder a parte de
los 1000 arrestados en estos días les
decomisamos todo hasta las colchonetas
para dormir les reaccionamos la comida y
ahora ya no verán el sol paren de matar
ya o ellos lo van a apagar también hasta
aquí las noticias sigan con france24
[Música]